2020, BUT AS ALWAYS, "THE STORY"
CONTINUES AND WE WILL SEE YOU
BACK HERE TOMORROW NIGHT.
A MUSICAL♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
"WHAT IS OUR GOAL, GET HIM TO
LIE SO WE CAN PROSECUTE OR GET
HIM FIRED?"
THOSE ARE FROM HANDWRITTEN NOTES
OF A SENIOR FBI OFFICIAL
PLOTTING WITH OTHERS TO FRAME
AND POTENTIALLY PROSECUTE
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN.
WE TOLD YOU EARLIER THIS WEEK,
AND THAT SMOKING GUN IT IS HERE.
BUT FIRST WE WANT TO BEGIN WITH
AN UPDATE ON THE STATE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
ON SATURDAY,
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WENT
GOLFING AT THE ROBERT TRENT
JONES COUNTRY CLUB.
OBAMA WAS DRIVEN TO THE COURSE
ABOUT 40 MILES FROM HIS HOME.
HERE’S A PICTURE OF IT FROM
POLITICO.
IF YOU LOOK YOU CAN SEE OBAMA IS
CLEARLY ENJOYING HIMSELF AND
OBVIOUSLY, WHY WOULDN’T HE BE.
IT’S BEAUTIFUL OUT ON THE LINKS.
AND NOTICED THERE AREN’T MANY
PEOPLE AROUND, BECAUSE BOTH
VIRGINIA AND WASHINGTON, D.C.,
ARE STILL UNDER QUARANTINE.
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN MARKED AT
HOME BUT BUT FOR HIM GOLFING AT
HIS COUNTRY CLUB WAS AN
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITY.
TWO DAYS LATER AFTER THIS
PICTURE WAS TAKEN, THE
BELEAGUERED RESIDENTS OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., BEGAN TO
RECEIVE A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT ON THEIR PHONES.
THE MESSAGE HAD BEEN RECORDED AT
THE REQUEST OF THE D.C.
GOVERNMENT BY BARACK OBAMA’S
WIFE.
HERE’S WHAT THE MESSAGE SAID.
>> REMEMBER, WE URGE YOU TO STAY
HOME EXCEPT IF YOU NEED A
CENTRAL HEALTH CARE, FOOD OR
SUPPLIES, OR TO GO TO HER
ESSENTIAL JOB.
>> Tucker: IT’S STAY HOME,
EXCEPT ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE,
ESSENTIAL FOOD, ESSENTIAL JOBS.
THAT IS MICHELLE OBAMA’S MESSAGE
TO YOU.
IT DID IT OCCUR TO HER THAT
THOSE STANDARDS ARE GOING TO
APPLY TO HER FAMILY AND THAT’S
WHY SHE DIDN’T MENTION ESSENTIAL
TRIPS TO THE COUNTRY CLUB?
THE FACT THAT THE RULES APPLY TO
THEM DOESN’T SEEM TO OCCUR TO
ANYONE IN POWER AT THE MOMENT.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO THE,
LORI LIGHTFOOT, THE MAYOR OF
CHICAGO WAS CAUGHT GETTING HER
HAIR DONE AT THE TIME THE CITY
OF CHICAGO HAD CLOSE SALONS TO
MERE CIVILIANS.
HER EXCUSE "I’M THE PUBLIC FACE
OF THE CITY" I AM A NATIONAL
MEDIA AND I’M OUT IN THE
PUBLIC EYE.
IN OTHER WORDS, I’M FAR MORE
IMPORTANT THAN YOU ARE, SHUT UP.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY OUR LEADERS
ARE MAKING A MOCKERY OF THE
QUARANTINES THEY SO
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENFORCED.
THEY HAD NO INTENTION OF ABIDING
BY THE RESTRICTIONS THAT THEY
IMPOSED ON THE CITIZENS, OUR
QUARANTINES ARE NOT ACHIEVING
WITH THE POLITICIANS CLAIMED
THEY WOULD ACHIEVE, NOT EVEN
CLOSE.
HUGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
INFECTED ANYWAY AND FAR FEWER OF
THEM ARE DYING THAN WE EXPECTED.
OUR POLITICAL LEADERS PRETEND AS
IF NONE OF THIS IS HAPPENING.
HE AND SHE COMMANDS PEOPLE TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES EXCEPT FOR
OCCASIONAL GROCERY SHOPPING.
MILLS PROHIBITED BARS,
RESTAURANTS, SUMMER CAMPS AND
SOME STATE PARKS FROM OPENING
AND MADE IT ILLEGAL FOR HOTELS
TO BOOK GUESTS, EVEN FOR A
FUTURE STAYS.
SHE CANCELED EVERY SUMMER
FESTIVAL IN THE STATE AND SHE
TOLD EVERY CHURCH TO KEEP ITS
DOORS LOCKED.
SHE SAID MANY OF THEM WILL GO
DEFUNCT FOREVER.
THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE ALL
NECESSARY, SHE EXPLAINED, THANKS
TO THE EXTREME AND UNUSUAL PERIL
THAT THE STATE OF MAINE FACES.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
WE ARE NOT OUT OF THE WOODS YET
AND LIKELY WILL NOT BE FOR SOME
TIME.
>> Tucker: NOT OUT OF THE
WORDS YET.
THOSE ARE BRACING WORDS.
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
WINSTON CHURCHILL MIGHT HAVE
SAID DURING THE BLITZ.
THE VERY MOMENT SHE SPOKE, A
GRAND TOTAL OF 33 PEOPLE WERE
BEING TREATED IN MAIN HOSPITALS
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
33 PEOPLE OUT OF A POPULATION OF
MORE THAN 1.3 MILLION PEOPLE.
OVER THE FULL COURSE OF THE
ENTIRE EPIDEMIC, JUST 51 PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF MAINE HAVE DIED
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
MEANWHILE, AND THERE IS ALWAYS A
FLIP SIDE, LIKELY BECAUSE OF THE
LOCKDOWNS THAT MILLS ORDERED,
MORE THAN 10% OF MAINE’S
POPULATION POPULATION IS NOW
UNEMPLOYED.
ALL OVER THE STATE, BUSINESSES
ARE FAILING.
OXFORD PREDICTS THAT MAINE WILL
BE HARDER AND LONGER IN THESE
LOCKDOWNS THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
IT’S NOT, IT’S VANDALISM.
>> PEOPLE WHO NOW ARE STAYING
APART SO THAT SOMEDAY WE CAN ALL
BE TOGETHER AGAIN.
THANKS GOVERNOR, WE APPRECIATE
YOUR KINDNESS IN ALLOWING THEM.
SO HOW LONG WILL IT BE UNTIL WE
CAN BE TOGETHER AGAIN?
MILLS, WHO IS CLEARLY DEEPLY
ENJOYING HER NEW FOUND POWER
DIDN’T SPECIFY HOW LONG.
THERE IS "NO TIMELINE FOR THAT.
THINGS WILL NOT BE NORMAL SOON"
SHE WARNED.
SO WE ARE WONDERING WHERE
EXACTLY JANET MILLS HAS A POWER
TO INVENT A NEW NORMAL FOR
1.3 MILLION PEOPLE, TO REMAKE
HUMAN SOCIETY IN WHATEVER FORM
SHE CHOOSES.
MILLS DID NOT EXPLAIN THAT
EITHER.
INSTEAD AT THE GOVERNOR READ A
SELECTION FROM A 31-YEAR-OLD
NOVELIST CALLED VERONICA ROTH
SHE SAID, GRITTING YOUR TEETH
THROUGH PAIN AS PART OF THE
"SLOW WALK TO A BETTER LIFE."
DEEP THOUGHTS FROM JANET MILLS,
THAT’S WHAT MILLS IS PROMISING.
BUT WAS THE LATEST EPIDEMIOLOGY
SCIENCE, THAT WAS LAST MONTH.
IT’S NOW ABOUT "A BETTER LIFE."
PEOPLE IN POWER ABUSE THEIR
POWER AND THAT MAY BE THE LESSON
HERE.
THE ARRIVAL OF THE TERRIFYING
NEW VIRUS FROM CHINA GAVE OUR
LEADER MORE POWER THAN ANYONE IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
SIX WEEKS AGO AMERICA WAS
SOMETHING REASONABLY AND IN
PERFECT DEMOCRACY.
BACK THEN, ANDREW CUOMO WAS
CONSIDERED A LIGATION POSSIBLY
CORRUPT REGIONAL LEADER BUT
SUDDENLY EVERYTHING IS CHANGED.
NOW IT’S AN OLIGARCHY MANAGED BY
BUREAUCRATS AND OF TECH MOGULS.
OUR LEADERS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
THAT WILL AFFECT YOUR FAMILY
FOREVER WITH VIRTUALLY NO
OVERSIGHT OR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OF COURSE, THEY LOVE IT.
WE SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISED IF
THEY DON’T WANTED TO END.
JEFF BEZOS FOR EXAMPLE HAS MADE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SINCE THE
LOCKDOWN BEGAN.
HOW SHOCKED ARE YOU THAT HIS
PERSONAL NEWSPAPER,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," IS
ARGUING WITH THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE VOLUMES OF THAT THE
LOCKDOWNS MUST CONTINUE?
NOT VERY SHOCKED.
THEY ALL FEEL THAT WAY.
THIS THE BEST THING THAT EVER
HAPPENED.
ON TWO SEPARATE OCCASIONS OTHERS
DISLIKE TO YOU AND DISLIKE YOUR
PROGRAM SO MUCH THAT THEY
ELECTED A CASINO OWNER FROM
REALITY TELEVISION INSTEAD.
WHAT IF THAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE PRETTY
STUNNED BY IT AND BITTER.
THEN ONE DAY YOU WAKE UP AND THE
COUNTRY IS IN CHAOS, NORMAL LIFE
IT HAS BEEN SUSPENDED.
THIS IS A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY,
AND YOU WOULD SEIZE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
AND SHE HAS.
>> EVERY FORM OF HEALTH CARE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE
INCLUDING REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND GETS US TO
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
THIS WOULD BE A TERRIBLE CRISIS
TO WASTE.
AS THE OLD SAYING GOES.
>> Tucker: UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE.
THOSE ARE THE REQUIRED RESPONSES
TO THE WILL HAND IN CORONAVIRUS
DECLARES HILLARY CLINTON.
EVERY POLITICIAN ON ALL SIDES
HAS A IN THE AND IDEOLOGICAL
WISH LIST THAT UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE KEPT IN CHECK
BY VOTERS.
AS A GROUP, VOTERS INSTINCTIVELY
DISTRUST IDEOLOGY FOR GOOD
REASON.
NOBODY IS KEEPING THOSE IDEAS IN
CHECK NOW AND NO ONE CARES WHAT
VOTERS THINK NOW.
IT’S TIME TO GOVERN WITHOUT
LIMITS.
WATCH DISGRACE TO
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO EXPLAINED
THAT AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OR SOMETHING WE NEED A
MORE "INCLUSION AND EQUITY."
>> THIS CITY WAS WRITTEN OFF
MORE TIMES THAN I CAN COUNT AND
THIS CITY CAME BACK STRONGER
EVERY TIME TIME.
AN IMMEDIATE ACTION THAT THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO TAKE AND
BUILD OUT AS PART OF THE BIGGER
VISION.
IT’S A TASK FORCE ON RACIAL
INCLUSION AND EQUITY.
FOCUSING ON THE DISPARITIES WE
ARE SEEING ALREADY, MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY PRESENT IN THE REALITY
IS WE ARE FACING WITH THIS
DISEASE.
>> Tucker: IT’S OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS REALLY ABOUT
STRUCTURAL RACISM, THAT’S WHAT
BILL de BLASIO WAS TELLING US.
I BET SHE DIDN’T KNOW THAT, SHE
ASSUMED IT WAS A VIRUS,
REMEMBER?
HOW CONFUSED ARE YOU?
IT DOESN’T MATTER BECAUSE